why don't Banks sort themselves out when
it comes to interest rate well we've
seen this in recent past and and over a
very very long period of time that when
there's a sort of change in the
structure of interest rates either
they're going up fast or going down fast
Banks win everybody else loses it's
completely unacceptable the treasury
committee have just had a short inquiry
with the big Banks asking them why is it
that you're passing on the cost of
borrowing immediately and yet your
interest rates accounts for people who
are trying to save or people who are on
fixed incomes are not reflecting those
Rises and interest rates and their their
answers were not persuasive
what did they say well for example they
were saying things like um we have a a
flexible saving rate a sort of a money
box account so that if you're saving on
a regular basis you get a very good rate
of interest well that's good but that's
a tiny amount of the money that's being
saved and I think there are all sorts of
restrictions around the age you had to
be a certain age and so on but actually
if you have something like well up to 60
of all our current accounts and your
average sort of interest rate on that is
about one percent one point seven
percent that's simply not good enough
and so the owners definitely is on the
banks to make sure that they're passing
on those rates not just to borrowers
well I mean in in since 2010 when I was
last on the treasury select committee
there was a great big change in the
number of banking licenses that have
been given out so competition is a great
big
um Game Changer in the financial
services sector there are now many many
more Banks many many more opportunities
for people to shop around so
competition's really important but so
too is encouraging consumers whether
they're borrowers or investors to
actually look at what's on offer to
recognize that there is a guarantee if
you're if you're depositing up to 85 000
pounds with a regulated bank then you've
protected that much is protected by
guarantee so you can deposit money with
a bank that perhaps isn't a High Street
Bank isn't one that you particularly
know of but if it's regulated always
must check you can get some much better
rates so just flicking through rates
today you could get a you know almost
four percent easy access rate I think
3.7 was the highest I saw still not
great I mean back back sort of in 2006
with with base rates last at the level
they are now 4.25 you could actually get
around six percent for your deposits
whereas now with base rate at four point
two five percent you're lucky if you get
two percent which is pretty shocking so
why is that I mean are these are these I
mean they'll not like me for saying
cartels but are they working as a cartel
no I I genuinely do not think that
that's the case I think that they are
relying on inertia however I mean I
don't know what the statistic is now but
I recall back in about 2011. there was
this shocking statistic which is that
you were more likely to get divorced
twice than you were to change your bank
account yeah it's pretty shocking isn't
it I think that has changed because as I
say we've seen many many more new
financial services companies coming into
the market lots more options out there
for consumers but still inertia is a big
problem for people so have a look around
have a look around is it hard is it as
hard to move your bank as it used to be
no it definitely isn't no um we've done
a lot to create bank account portability
since um the conservatives have been in
government since 2010 so there's there's
been a lot of changes so for example if
you do move your bank account now you
can move all of your standing orders and
direct debits through an automated
process semi-automated process so it
makes it much easier you're not having
to sort of start again and try and
remember you know who was your TV
licensing you know direct debit to Etc
yeah so it's all done for you so it does
make it much much easier than it used to
be but generally speaking people are
still like yeah but I've got my bank
account number and my you know my bank
cards and I can't bother them off the
top of my head because if I let you go
we're almost out of time but
um this vat
um free tourist tax yes we know that a
lot of businesses in the UK are really
unhappy about that because people
Shoppers are going to Milan or Paris
instead what would you say to the
government
um I I I'm very sympathetic to that just
down the road from my constitutions is
best to shopping Village is a huge
incredible tourist attraction does
massive amount of business and they've
certainly uh lobbied me about this issue
with v80 I mean it's difficult isn't it
you do want everybody who comes here to
pay their Fair taxes but on the other
hand if we're losing out to other
centers who are offering vat free
shopping and then we're sort of
scuppering ourselves so I think it's a
difficult decision but I certainly think
it's one the government should very
carefully assess whether we're actually
net losing out by scrapping the vat
refunds and whether we should actually
perhaps reinstate them for the sake of
attracting more tourist Shoppers so
we're out of time but the chancellor
should look at that again I think so
okay it's good to see you thanks for
coming yeah